the labour party isn't calling for visa
waivers at this point is it even though
we have this situation where people
can't get into this country because of
the bureaucracy we're calling for
emergency visas to be issued a much
simpler faster process
where you can do the biometrics and
security checks on the spot and then
have an emergency visa without people
having to fill in 14 pages of forms
without them people having to struggle
to kind of upload documents while
they're in a back of a car
fleeing trying to get to safety because
i think what we've seen is just really
shambolic and it's not fair on people
who have already fled a war zone people
who have already endured so much had to
leave behind
so much
and have fled a russian bombardment they
should be able to get to safety and join
family and that's what really this is
about and the concern against that from
the government is that it may well let
in people who are not actually fleeing
violence they're trying to get into
britain for nefarious reasons we can do
the biometric and security checks on the
spot the problem with the what the
government's done is first of all
they've not had the proper centers in
place they've not set up emergency
centers in order to be able to do
biometrics or security checks they've
not done the proper planning to look at
whether they could use the same
technology that they used for hong kong
so that you can do a lot of those checks
online and then they've made it really
complicated so they're sort of picking
and choosing between families rather
than just saying everybody should be
able to come to join family or friends
we know most people want to stay in
poland or in hungary or close to ukraine
and close to home but those who've got
family or friends
are reaching out to people who can look
after them and instead they're having to
to meet all kinds of technical
requirements rather than just having a
very simple system in place so this
could be done much much faster we just
shouldn't have these delays we should
have something proper in place that can
let families reunite at such an awful
time i mean the comparison to hong kong
quite fair i mean would you want there
to be sent to set up at every single
entry point into the uk because that
would be unworkable wouldn't it
it's i mean obviously every country is
different so the issues the minister
himself said yesterday that they were
looking at whether they could use the
technology that they used for hong kong
well look faster i mean why wasn't this
being done
weeks ago when british intelligence were
warning for some time that an invasion
from russia into ukraine was imminent
and that's the thing they didn't put
that planning in place they haven't set
up enough emergency centers and so
you've got this awful situation where
families make it all the way to calais
you know someone who's driven their
niece who they went to pick up had
driven all the way back to cali and then
being sent to brussels where the center
is only open three days a week i mean
how can that be
when there is a war on in europe that
you have you're one of your
centers that is close to closest to
calais only open three days a week and
that's the thing the home office really
should be getting a grip on and it is
shambolic and shameful that they have
failed to do something so basic now in
regards to that the home office will be
saying that it's the security element
that you need to be careful of it's
being uh talked about this morning the
kremlin operatives masquerading as
ukrainians i mean your shadow home
secretary you wouldn't want those
criminals coming in at all so there has
to be some checks in place don't you and
i'm saying do the security checks but
you can do these recent security checks
on the spot they're really quick to do
well if you talk to border force
officials you talk to people who do
funding
this is basic stuff to do that they
should be able to do if you look at what
other countries are doing to support
ukraine you know obviously poland
hungary they're doing the most because
they are the neighboring countries and
that is where people are wanting to stay
but really it should not be beyond the
width of the home office to make sure
they've got enough staff in place to do
the security checks they've got the
technology to do it they should be able
to do this on the spot and do this much
more quickly the problem is what we've
seen from the home office is they just
resisted this all the way along they're
still saying some family members for
example if you are
a health care worker if you work in a
british hospital you're ukrainian here
on a healthcare visa you can't bring
your elderly mom to come and live with
you even if she's fled keith or she's
fled bombardment in ukraine and that's
not right i don't think that's what
people i mean we've seen of course we've
seen this war coming what do you put
this down to then the fact that it does
seem to be so difficult for the home
office to get a grip of the situation
because people are struggling on the
border to be honest i don't get it
because other departments have been
planning other departments have been
working on this and preparing and you
know
we've worked because with the the
foreign office with other departments we
have been pressing the treasury and
other departments to go much further and
faster with sanctions but we are working
with them to do this it's the home
office that seems to have been so
resistant it tried to use the original
visa system if you remember we had that
awful moment when the home office
minister said well people should come
here and apply for a seasonal
agricultural visa they should come and
pick fruit well that's clearly not the
answer when you've got desperate
families fleeing conflict is this the
result of having that tough border
policy that has been put in place
post-brexit
i think it's not i actually don't think
this is about brexit i think this is
about a home office that is not
actually looking at what is happening to
families and not responding properly you
know to be fair actually the i think the
government did do the right thing on
hong kong did provide visas and that
system worked really well
but they have just been sort of
blinkered they've just not looked
properly at what needs to happen for
ukraine and while i've got you here
cooper you will have seen what happened
with john berko yesterday being found
guilty you sent out a tweet in 2019
there's always a tweet where you said
that you would miss him do you still
miss him
yeah i've you know they i haven't seen
the report but i have seen the some of
the reports on it and it's obviously
really troubling i mean he's not
apologetic at all right i think we've
had an independent process you have to
respect an independent process that's
done proper investigations and the
conclusions are i think really troubling
the labour party has suspended john
berker from membership and that's the
right thing to do there's obviously that
process still going through so i can't
comment on that but it's the right
response you would have worked for a
long time did you see any of the
bullying see any of this behavior i
didn't but i also think that you have to
respect the independent investigation
and process that that's happened i think
you know it's important that that we do
that it's been wrong in the past when
politicians of any party have tried to
ignore independent processes or overturn
them we saw that happen with owen
patterson that was wrong equally it
would be wrong to to challenge or to try
and overturn over independent process in
this case and and i think we have to
respect it and obviously you know those
are very troubling conclusions certainly
okay
thank you very much
thank you